start resisting only on these if you
start resisting you're going to go home
with injuries all right so there's
there's time for being strong and
there's time for trying to blend you
know we both learn something
this
is called Roku now a lot of you are
going back here and then you're having
to put something on
now Roku it means just means a six point
two gokio is normally knife taking we
know ikio Nico senko yonkyo but we
rarely talk about gokio and Roku but
Roku is about the worst one you want
somebody powerful to do on you because
it'll either snap the elbow or really
hurt the elbow so that's why I'm trying
to be kind in saying go easy but where
you turn
changes on Roku and it changes depending
on what the how the past is coming so if
the person is coming straight at you
by going round the back
you know he can perhaps resist me and
come back up
so in this case because he's coming
forward we need to go forward
here I need to
punch him forward all right and if he
comes up
I'm not doing anything that's him who's
trying to get up look I'm just staying
here
I am adding a little bit more now down
on the wrist
well you can't see
no
but
all right so by some of you are sweeping
that's all I'm saying now if it was a
Joe ski you really want to go what I
call Upstream with him you want to go
sort of up that way first and then
put the brakes on
so a lot of you are just
going around
I'm wondering now that's why he's not
got it on I should have been about there
right so there's a place where it can go
on there's a place where it can't go on
he likes the training so it's good
oh yeah no more all right so please if
it doesn't feel right you know if he
doesn't feel I was sort of looking at
Raj earlier and I thought
he's there but he's not he's sort of
thinking ain't quite right but you don't
know where to step so it's the cutting
the cake always sometimes it's right
round here
right around here and then here another
time it might be I say come lead them up
and here so there's no place I can tell
you where the feet should be
you should feel that as a as an aikidoka
right if it doesn't feel right where
you've done it this time try a new place
next time
because we're all individuals and we all
act differently okay
[Music]
not saying there isn't anybody
um you can't really do a rocker unless
it's from a ski either a ski with a Joe
or you know ski with a Ken it needs to
be going forward
okay
so
if I done rocker as a lot of you seniors
will know it
I'd take underneath
but but look I can't trap his hand now
see I can't tap his hand why would he
turn why would he turn that
if he now does the ski
ski
that's so so Roku can be done from skis
because they're turning
their hand usually
so I just I was thinking about this and
I thought well a lot of people don't get
that but if they start to learn the
angle they can actually see how
you know you can start to mold things
so what is this what is this technique
what is this technique
Nick yeah
so so you're starting to lock on okay
the next one the most of you should know
is Kota gosh
since he was always very accurate about
this thumb must be on this
knuckle here
when we hold the can or Joe we hold it
always with these two fingers
okay the rest of the fingers are there
but there's there shouldn't be any real
power there
and when they and because we take
taijitsu from the weapons here's a good
example of I can get two fingers in here
but I can't get the whole hand in
so between the thumb and the two fingers
you've got the technique
so you're here
you can attemi if you want you know you
can add the this
but today I'm more interested in getting
to here
step
this way
but as you step this way don't bring
this around this hip but push it to him
there's your tummy
push it to him
you can't do normal guys who else you're
going to need a new offend or something
so here
for the seniors what I'd like for the
seniors is when I do it down here inside
my stomach I feel this turn
when I go like that I feel this turn
that adds Mass
so I'm creating mass so
when do you start learning about this
yellow belt always about you learn it
when your time is to absorb it
top one two
I've got him there
look take this out
there's the current guys there's a
couple of guys
push it towards him
you seen you as I want you now to
connect this make the circle
inside your body
step across like normal car guys now
when this back leg spins you take the
can
and you finish the cut
okay
and you should
so I'm I'm looking at you seniors and
saying if this isn't happening then you
you need to work on it don't worry about
him tapping
okay done well
so let's try